[Música]
en directo América hablamos de economía
pero yo me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañera Daniela Blandón Daniela
bienvenida vamos a iniciar con las
reuniones de primavera del fondo
monetario internacional y del Banco
Mundial palentina pues Washington es la
sede de este encuentro en el que
anualmente se hace una actualización de
las previsiones económicas esta vez una
coyuntura incierta en la que se espera
que el 90% de las economías avanzadas
crezca menos y cuando en un intento de
luchar contra la inflación se están
enfrentando agresivas subidas de las
tasas de interés y también a las
turbulencias financieras
la recuperación que tanto anhelamos una
recuperación sólida todavía es un poco
difícil de alcanzar
por qué porque tenemos un problema de
inflación significativo
eso significa que los bancos centrales
tienen que continuar manteniendo las
tasas de altas para combatirlo Y eso
está en camino de restaurar las
perspectivas de un crecimiento sólido
Valentina le invito a que saque la
calculadora porque ellos dicen que las
tasas volverán a sus niveles prepandemia
pero solamente cuando la inflación
vuelva a su objetivo y lo de un ejemplo
Estados Unidos lleva un año tratando de
llevarla del 9 al 2% anual y apenas van
el 6% en un año sí Hay que sacar la
calculadora Daniela Bueno pero mira esto
tan curioso las tasas de interés altas
que son la normativa o la norma en
muchos países no son regla en todo el
mundo no y el mejor ejemplo de ello es
el Banco Central de Japón que es uno de
los menos ortodoxos y que ha optado por
mantenerlas Ultra baja en contravida de
lo que están haciendo sus colegas Lo
cierto es que la inflación objetivo al
igual que en otros países es del 2%
anual y en 2022 cerró en 2,3%. muchos
creen que es un caso de éxito pero otros
subrayan que esta estrategia ha traído
efectos secundarios Como por ejemplo la
fuerte deva luación del yen a otras
frente a otras Divisas hoy comenzó el
mandato de su nuevo gobernador casual y
esto anticipó
en general los bancos parecen Tener
suficiente reservas y la intermediación
financiera está funcionando a pleno
rendimiento el banco de Japón también ha
tomado varias medidas para mitigar el
costo de las tasas negativas por lo
tanto dado que la inflación aún no
alcanza el 2% anual es apropiado
mantener esas tasas negativas bueno
Daniela la vamos a cambiar de tema
porque el presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula Silva que acaba de cumplir
100 días en el poder se fue en contra de
una empresa francesa pues aprovecho
precisamente estos 100 primeros días y
la reunión Ministerial para hacerle una
advertencia a la cadena minorista
francesa
cometieron otro delito de racismo un
guardia de carrefour acompañó a una
chica negra que iba a comprar algo
pensando que iba a robar ella tuvo que
quitarse el sostén y las bragas para
demostrar que no iba a robar es la
segunda vez que carrefour hace este tipo
de cosas según el mandatario esto
sucedió en curitiba y es el segundo caso
después de otros similar denunciado por
vin
cius él es el esposo de una jugadora de
la selección de voleibol y relató que
una cajera de un carrefour en Sao Paulo
se negó a atenderlo en la fila
preferente a pesar de que en ese momento
estaba vacía y a pesar también de que
después recibió sin mayores problemas a
una cliente Blanca a este caso carrefour
respondió que despidió de inmediato la
cajera y que no tolera este tipo de
actitudes En todo caso en 2020 de este
grupo se vio envuelto en otro caso de
racismo un hombre negro recibió una
paliza mortal de dos guardias de
seguridad blancos en el parqueadero de
un supermercado en Porto alegre seis
personas fueron acusadas formalmente por
ese crimen Daniela cerramos con la cifra
del día
377 millones esta fue la taquilla en los
primeros cinco días de Super Mario Bros
the movie en las más de 4.000 salas de
cine en que se estrenó la semana pasada
en Estados Unidos y también en el resto
del mundo y mira eso Valentina marcó
varios récords es la adaptación más
exitosa de videojuegos superando
ampliamente a World Craft también gana
en películas animadas después después de
superar los 358 millones de dólares de
Frozen 2 en sus primeros cinco días
también es el mayor estreno de 2023 y
como si fuera poco es un récord para
illumination que es la tienda de
animación detrás de estas exitosas
franquicias como Minions que esta vez se
unió con Nintendo para crear Mario Bros
Super Mario la película ya la vio pues
no la he visto pero ya tengo mucha
curiosidad Daniela tengo que ir los que
crecimos jugando Super Mario tenemos que
verla Muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica la invito a que continúe con
nosotros que nosotros Seguimos aquí en
directo América con directo